este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
surf no os doy más detalles pero antes
vamos con nuestra historia de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ucrania es el elefante en la habitación
de europa pensando bien en europa es el
continente más pacífico del planeta
salvo por ucrania este país se ve
invadido por rusia desde hace más de 6
años y la pregunta es qué está haciendo
la otan al respecto en anteriores vídeos
de visual política os hemos contado
porque ucrania es el país más pobre de
europa y si es cierto el principal
factor para explicar toda esta miseria
es la corrupción de las propias élites
ucranianas ahora bien que es innegable
que la invasión rusa hace que sea muy
difícil que ucrania pueda salir de la
pobreza fijaos en este mandato
[Música]
desde el año 2014 la península de crimea
está controlada directamente por rusia
además estas dos regiones del este que
se llaman tönnies y lugansk están
controladas por separatistas que a su
vez están apoyados por rusia no
solamente hablamos de que el país ya
está dividido es que además en cualquier
momento rusia podría intentar conquistar
más regiones y la pregunta es montaría
es una fábrica o una oficina en ucrania
sabiendo que en cualquier momento la
ciudad dónde estáis puede entrar en
guerra y ya sé lo que me dirá uno venga
a fonseca la verdad que es que rusia
podría invadir más partes de ucrania y
la respuesta es y por qué no pensarlo
así la guerra entre ucrania y rusia es
totalmente desigual y kanye gasta en
ejército unos cinco mil doscientos
millones de dólares al año
rusia gasta 65 mil millones de dólares
al año y todo esto explica que noticias
como estas sean tan preocupantes 11 de
mayo de 2021 ucrania dice que rusia
tiene todavía 100.000 tropas cerca de la
frontera por el momento rusia no ha
avanzado sus posiciones al menos no
desde el año 2014 pero si algún día lo
hicieran que podría hacer ucrania como
podrían defenderse como os podéis
imaginar la situación de este país es
crítica
y que el mayor deseo de los ucranianos
en estos días sea este 6 de abril de
ucrania quiera acelerar la entrada en la
otan para enviar una señal real a rusia
y diréis pero por qué es tan importante
que ucrania entró en la otan por si
alguno no lo sabe la otan es una unión
de defensa colectiva es decir que si
atacas a un país miembro el resto está
obligado a defender lo dicho de otra
forma si ucrania fuera un país miembro
de la otan tanto eeuu como alemania
francia o españa tendrían que mandar
tropas para defenderles
es decir que ya no estarían solos frente
al imperio ruso la pregunta es es
posible que ucrania de verdad entre en
la otan de verdad la otan estaría
dispuesto a aceptar les y lo que es más
importante como se está preparando el
ejército de ucrania para defenderse de
un posible nuevo ataque de rusia hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a hablar de defensa en
internet si vuestro móvil o vuestro
ordenador es como ucrania también está a
merced de una invasión en cualquier
momento lo que pasa es que en este caso
no sería una invasión de tanques sino de
hackers hackers rusos norcoreanos o de
cualquier otro lugar incluso que no
seáis conscientes es muy probable que
ahora mismo
que esté leyendo vuestros mensajes y
robando información personal de buscas
tarjetas de crédito etcétera y diréis
cuál es la mejor forma de protegernos
del ciberataque
[Música]
exacto utilizando una vpn una vpn como
subsal vpn cursar es la vpn favorita de
visual polític por muchas razones no
solo nos protege de hackers bots e
propaganda y virus además permite que
podamos entrar en cualquier sitio de
internet sin encontrarnos con esos
mensajes tan horribles de esta página
está bloqueada en tu país
vamos que puedes visitar cualquier sitio
web de forma segura además de usar tiene
una herramienta que se llama clean web
que bloquea todos esos popups de
propaganda por donde se cuelan un montón
de bots y cookies que francamente no
queremos tenerlos
por si todo esto fuera poco con una
misma cuenta de surf shark podrás
registrar todos los dispositivos que
quieras quieres navegar con seguridad
desde tu smartphone o desde tu teléfono
móvil o desde tu ordenador personal pues
puedes hacer todo eso con una única
cuenta de surf shark vpn y por supuesto
tenemos un descuento de lujo para todos
vosotros que seguís visual polític si
utilizáis el código político terminado
hincada visual político tendréis un 83
por ciento de descuento más tres meses
extra totalmente gratuitos tenéis el
link en la descripción no esperéis más y
descargados ya la aplicación y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
podcast chanchullos y kalashnikovs dicen
que una imagen vale más que mil palabras
así que os voy a enseñar una imagen para
que entendáis cómo funcionaba el
ejército de ucrania hasta la guerra de
2014 esto que os voy a enseñar ahora es
real es un anuncio oficial para
enrolarse al ejército de ucrania vamos a
verlo juntos porque no tiene desperdicio
[Música]
bien aquí vemos a lo que sería el
clásico palurdo ucraniano que está
intentando ligar con unas damiselas
mostrando su flamante bmw algo muy
normal de ucrania pero de repente ocurre
algo inesperado aparece un tanque algo
también muy normal en ucrania por lo
visto y en ese tanque hay tres soldados
que llevan tanto maquillaje encima que
parecen el novio de la barba y aquí es
cuando se baja del soldado dmitri y
atentos porque este es el momento clave
del anuncio
bien muy bien con dos meses está
conducido un tanque pero te vas a tomar
un vodka así para que te dé alegría os
recuerda una vez más que este vídeo está
hecho por el gobierno de ucrania o sea
esta es la visión que tenía a ucrania de
lo que era su ejército pero esperad un
momento porque la historia si vale las
chicas pasando el palurdo ya sabéis
chicos si algún día queréis ligar en
ucrania tan que mejor que bmw y aquí
tenéis al soldado dmitri bebiendo no un
chupito de vodka sino el botijo entero
vale ahora hablar un ratito que si
siguen a trabajo en el ejército que si
tienes insta que si me quiero casar
contigo y bien después los soldados se
van a hacer sus cosas de soldados fin
del anuncio ejército de ucrania porque
elegir entre hacer el amor o hacer la
guerra cuando puedes tener los dos bien
después de esta obra de arte os voy a
dar unos datos que os van a dejar
petrificados ucrania pese a todo lo que
hemos visto es uno de los mayores
exportadores de armas del mundo
tal cual como lo oís y grace como puede
ser pues porque durante la época
soviética ucrania producía el 30 por
ciento del armamento de toda la unión
soviética hablamos de un millón de
personas que trabajaban en las más de
750 fábricas de armas ucranianas
y diréis qué pasó cuando se disolvió la
unión soviética pues algo que seguro que
nos va a sorprender casi todo el arsenal
soviético desapareció así tal cual como
logís se calcula que entre 1992 y 1998
ucrania perdió más de 32 mil millones de
dólares en armamento y donde fueron a
parar todas las armas pues a guerras
como la de sierra leona croacia etcétera
esta fue la época dorada de los
traficantes de armas ilegales por cierto
que esta historia la cuenta muy bien en
la película el señor de la guerra con
nicolas cage pero la historia no se
queda aquí dejando un lado a los
traficantes de armas ilegales el estado
ucraniano también hizo un enorme negocio
con el armamento
todas estas antiguas fábricas soviéticas
seguían produciendo y que fabricaban
pues principalmente piezas para armas
rusas por ejemplo la mayor parte de los
motores que usaban los helicópteros
rusos tenían la etiqueta made in you
creen para que os hagáis una idea en el
año 2012 ucrania fue el cuarto mayor
exportador de armas del mundo y sus
principales clientes eran pakistán china
y por supuesto rusia todo esto explica
que hasta el año 2014 la mayoría de los
ucranianos dijeran no a entrar el 29 de
marzo de 2010 ucrania dice no a la otan
no es sorprendente que más de la mitad
de los sucre menos el 51% diera una nota
negativa a la otan y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando con tanta arma ucrania
tiene que ser toda una potencia militar
como es posible entonces que rusia se
atreviera a invadir les pues hay dos
cosas muy importantes que tenemos que
entender la primera es que ucrania sólo
exportaba piezas para fabricar armas es
decir que a duras penas eran capaz de
producir un arma completa
ah
pero no sólo eso como os podéis imaginar
la industria militar ucraniana tampoco
era ajena a la corrupción para que os
hagáis una idea en el año 2010 todas las
empresas estatales de armamento se
unificaron bajo un mismo conglomerado
ucr oboronprom
esta empresa da trabajo a más de 80 mil
personas sin embargo en 10 años apenas
han llegado a fabricar un único tanque
entero como viene siendo habitual en
este país casi todo el dinero destinado
armamento terminó en los bolsillos de
los oligarcas y los políticos y
tecnologías del ejército pues viendo el
vídeo que se ha puesto al principio ya
os podéis hacer una idea en el año 2014
ucrania tenía 168 mil soldados por
ejemplo el ejército de tierra tenía 41
mil tropas pero sólo seis mil estaban
listas para combatir y cuando digo
listas para combatir me refiero a que
estaban entrenadas y equipadas es decir
que sólo seis mil soldados tenían cosas
tan básicas como un par de botas traje
de camuflaje y fusil con este panorama
entenderéis por qué la invasión rusa fue
un paseo militar y la pregunta que os
estaréis haciendo es cómo puede
defenderse ucrania han cambiado su
ejército o tarde o temprano van a
terminar rindiéndose pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
un ejército pagado por crowdfunding por
si alguno está un poco perdido en esta
historia vamos a hacer un resumen muy
rápido
la guerra de ucrania resumida en 15
segundos en el año 2013 miles de
ucranianos salieron a protestar a las
calles y derrocaron al gobierno que era
propicio en 2014 ucrania nombró un nuevo
gobierno que era anti ruso esto provocó
que las regiones resultantes de ucrania
se quisieran separar del país ruso y
medio la península de crimea y apoyó a
los rebeldes separatistas del donbass ya
lo sé esto es un resumen con brocha muy
gorda pero si queréis más detalles
tenemos un montón de vídeos no lo
comentamos más en profundidad los
encontraréis en la descripción por
cierto este es un buen momento para
recordaros que sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribirse a
este canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones pero sigamos con la
historia como ya hemos dicho ucrania
apenas tenía soldados para combatir en
el frente entonces qué ocurría cuando
rusia les invadió pues que miles de
civiles se fueron a la guerra por su
propia cuenta y riesgo
[Música]
tal cual como lo es gente como
cualquiera de vosotros o como yo mismo
sin entrenamiento ni armas ni ningún
tipo de equipamiento que de repente se
montó en su coche y se fue el frente a
combatir así es como nacieron los
batallones de voluntarios
[Música]
estos batallones había gente de todo
tipo de ideologías y si si seguís
canales de propaganda rusa ya sabréis
que muchos de ellos eran de grupos
neonazis pero es que junto a ellos
también había grupos musulmanes
y diréis musulmanes en ucrania pero que
pintan los musulmanes en ucrania pues
por ejemplo el batallón sheikh mansour
eran guerreros que venían de chechenia
para apoyar la causa y os preguntaréis
pero de qué sirve generan muchos
guerreros si ni siquiera tienen armas
pensad que todos estos voluntarios
podrían ser una persona como cualquiera
de vosotros os imagináis que de repente
termina 6 combatiendo en un frente de
guerra como conseguiría es un fusil
quien os lo pagaría pues atentos 24 de
mayo de 2015 financiando una guerra por
crowdfunding en una batalla de david
contra goliat las fuerzas ucranianas
usan empresas privadas y organizaciones
de voluntarios financiadas por club
funding para desarrollar software y
drones en su guerra contra rusia habéis
oído bien ante el vacío dejado por el
ejército oficial los ucranianos se
organizaron a su manera y así es como
surgieron ong es como con back alive que
compraba chalecos antibalas y gafas de
visión nocturna para los soldados
[Música]
solo esta ong llegó a recaudar más de
100 mil dólares en sus primeros 45 días
de vida y diréis pero de dónde sacaban
tanto dinero en un país tan pobre como
ucrania la respuesta está en la diáspora
ucraniana
hay más de 20 millones de ucranianos
dispersos por el mundo 345 mil viven en
estados unidos y tienen dinero
suficiente como para hacer las
donaciones que hagan falta así que en
muy poco tiempo estos ejércitos de
voluntarios recaudaron millones de
dólares para comprar armas botas y toda
clase de equipamiento militar y alguno
estará pensando pues qué historia más
bonita verdad un ejército creado por el
pueblo en realidad hay otro nombre mucho
más feo para designar esta práctica en
realidad estamos hablando de tráfico
ilegal de armas todo esto explica
noticias como este 5 de octubre de 2018
paypal no funciona en ucrania aunque los
ucranianos se encuentran formas de
utilizarlo pero no sólo hablamos de
paypal una de las condiciones que puso
estados unidos para enviar armas a
ucrania fue que todos esos grupos de
voluntarios se incorporasen al ejército
regular de hecho para el año 2019 casi
todos estos voluntarios eran soldados
regulares
y aquí es donde si vienen las buenas
noticias porque estas fuerzas
voluntarias que ahora estaban en el
ejército regular estaba mucho más
motivadas y eran más difíciles de
corromper recordáis que en 2014 ucrania
apenas tenía soldados listos para el
combate pues ahora mismo
hablamos de 250.000 tropas no tienen un
armamento especialmente bueno pero al
menos todos tienen botas traje de
camuflaje y fusil el ejército de ucrania
ha cambiado de arriba a abajo pero eso
es mejor que lo veáis por vosotros
mismos atentos al anuncio que sacó el
ejército de ucrania en el año 2016 para
reclutar soldados
[Música]
superior
creo que sobran las palabras en
cualquier caso la pregunta que se
estaría saliendo ahora es y es esto es
suficiente para defenderse de un ataque
de rusia o sigue siendo necesaria la
ayuda de la otan pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
puede ucrania entrar en la otan la
respuesta corta esta pregunta es no
quiero decir nadie puede predecir el
futuro y aquí en visual polític desde
luego no tenemos una bola de cristal
pero es muy difícil pensar que ucrania
entre la otan porque pues por una razón
muy simple si ucrania entrar en la otan
rusia tendría a su archienemigo en la
frontera eso es razón suficiente para
que rusia pudiera entrar en guerra
abierta para evitarlo es decir que
existe un riesgo muy alto y por triste
que suene para los ucranianos que veáis
este vídeo el beneficio no compensa un
riesgo tan alto podríamos decir que esta
es la idea que ha guiado la postura de
eeuu y la unión europea en los últimos
años
[Música]
y diréis entonces nadie está dispuesto a
hacer nada por defender a ucrania pues
tampoco exactamente solo que lo quieren
hacer de otra forma veréis desde el año
2014 eeuu ha gastado más de 2500
millones de dólares en ayuda militar a
ucrania puede parecer mucho dinero que
en realidad es una propina si lo
comparamos con los más de 64 billones de
dólares que se han gastado en guerras en
oriente medio desde 2001 y si digo
billones en castellano en inglés sería
trillions en cualquier caso este dinero
ha sido suficiente para enviar un
arsenal que ha sido clave para evitar
bajas por ejemplo ucrania cuenta ahora
con más de 300 hamlisch que son eso los
todoterrenos blindados que habéis visto
en las películas también han enviado
radares de artillería se calcula que
sólo con esto ucrania ha reducido las
bajas en un 60%
[Música]
la otan también ha enviado a miles de
instructores para que entrenar a los
soldados y diréis eso es todo ni
siquiera han enviado cañones y fusiles a
fin de cuentas tanto los radares como
los cambios nos sirven para atacar y
estamos hablando de una guerra donde
están las armas letales y aquí es donde
volvemos a lo que decíamos al principio
de este capítulo la otan quiere evitar
los ataques a toda costa porque el
objetivo es evitar que la situación se
escale y esto se ve muy bien con este
ejemplo
17 de junio de 2020 ucrania obtiene
ayuda militar de eeuu incluyendo misiles
antitanques javelin habéis jugado al
call of duty alguna vez si es así seguro
que conoceréis los lanzacohetes ya
veréis
se trata de un sistema de lanzacohetes
portátil es decir que lo puedes llevar
al hombro y disparar proyectiles
destinadas a destruir tanques eso sí es
un arma letal y no creáis que hablamos
de un arma cualquiera para que os hagáis
una idea cada uno de los cañones de
berlín cuesta 280 mil dólares pero esto
es sólo el cañón cada cohete vale 174
mil dólares es decir que un solo disparo
de un ya verín vale lo mismo que un piso
en casi cualquier ciudad del miembro
[Música]
podéis imaginar estos cohetes serían
cruciales en una batalla contra tanques
rusos sin embargo todos estos
lanzamisiles ya venían vienen con un
plan ya no puede tener sus 37 flamantes
llave link en la línea de combate tal
cual como lois están obligados a
guardarlos en un depósito en las
regiones del oeste del país que están a
cientos de kilómetros de la zona de
guerra
[Música]
y diréis porque qué sentido tiene enviar
armas a un país para luego no dejarles
que las usen está respuesta está en una
palabra disuasión ni eeuu ni la otan
quieren que ucrania ataque a rusia y
despierte la cólera de vladimir putin
así que se limitan al armamento
suficiente para disuadir a rusia de
escalar la guerra dicho de otra forma
que por el momento es muy difícil pensar
que ucrania llegue a entrar en la otan
ahora bien la otan está ayudando a
ucrania para que moderniza su ejército y
puede resistir nuevos ataques con el
menor número de bajas posibles
[Música]
pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
veis que esto será suficiente volveremos
a ver nuevos ataques de rusia es
cuestión de tiempo que la otan llegue a
entrar de lleno en este conflicto y digo
que es más importante creéis que ucrania
podrá modernizar su ejército de verdad o
la corrupción hará que esto sea
imposible podéis dejarnos vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios
antes de terminar quiero darle las
gracias a yago rodríguez del canal cosas
militares por haberme ayudado con la
investigación para este vídeo como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
político sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a este canal
y darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]